- So, as you might've heard,
Florida passed this law
that attempted to prevent
social media platforms
from deplatforming political candidates
and political speech.
Not surprisingly, industry
groups have already pushed back
and they're almost certainly going to win,
for at least two reasons.
First of all, Section 230,
the infamous Communications Decency Act,
Section 230 explicitly
allows social media platforms
to moderate their own content.
And, most importantly, that
law preempts state law,
it's a federal law that effectively
prevents states from
passing laws like this.
And then second of all,
there is the First Amendment.
These are private companies
and they are largely in charge
of what speech they allow or
don't allow on their platforms.
So it's unlikely that this Florida law
is going to last very long
because we're going to see it in court.